usualmente cuando se hablan de
inversiones hay dos palabras que suenan
muchísimo que son riesgo y recompensa
déjame escribirle por aquí riesgo riesgo
y recompensa recompensa
y no es casualidad que se mencionan
muchos de ellos se mencionan casi
siempre juntas y van de la mano y tiene
que ver que cuando invertimos pues hay
una cierta relación entre el riesgo y la
recompensa lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es ver justamente cuál es esa
relación y para eso vamos a ver varios
ejemplos sale entonces supongamos que en
un determinado año yo ya gaste todo lo
que tenía que gastar pague mis deudas y
me sobraron diez mil pesos diez mil
pesos y entonces esos diez mil pesos los
quiero invertir es decir quiero pues
prestar los o depositarlos en algún
lugar para obtener más dinero
entonces vamos a pensar en algunas
opciones que puedo hacer con esos diez
mil pesos y vamos a ver qué riesgo y
recompensa tienen asociadas entonces una
primera opción y claro no voy a ser
exhaustivo hay muchísimas más opciones
que las que te voy a contar pero bueno
vamos a ver varias de esas entonces una
primera opción sería meter el dinero al
banco en una cuenta de ahorros en una
cuenta de ahorros
ahorros entonces eso básicamente es que
vas al banco depositas tu dinero y ahí
va generando un cierto interés entonces
cuál sería la recompensa recompensa pues
la recompensa está dada justamente en
función del interés que te están pagando
y digamos que es del 1% anual vale anual
entonces qué quiere decir esto qué
quiere decir un interés del 1% anual que
al principio del año depositas 10 mil
pesos y al final del año te dan un 1%
más aquí serían 100 pesos más al final
tendrías 10 mil 100 pesos bueno ahora
vamos a pensar qué sucede con el riesgo
de meter el dinero en el banco entonces
aquí le voy a poner riesgo con otro
color riesgo y bueno déjame déjame decir
que esta cuenta de ahorros no es
cualquier cuenta de ahorros de hecho
ésta es una cuenta de ahorros respaldada
por el ipab
y pub qué es esto del ipab pues es una
institución que se dedica a proteger los
ahorros de varias cuentas de banco que
te asegura que aunque el banco no te
pueda pagar ellos te van a pagar a
través del banco de méxico o como se la
base las arregle entonces el chiste es
que ellos hasta cierto límite están
dispuestos a pagarte lo que hayas
depositado en el banco si es que el
banco no puede hacer entonces con esto
en mente básicamente el riesgo de meter
tu dinero en esta cuenta de ahorros es
de cero déjame ponerlo con el color de
riesgo es de cero y lo importantísimo es
que estaba respaldada por el ipab
entonces bueno si quieres ir y meter tu
dinero en el banco tienes que ver que
esté respaldado por el pago y sería muy
recomendable que lo estuviera bueno esa
es una primera opción en la cual puedo
invertir mi dinero vamos a pasar a otra
más supongamos ahora que no sé
qué quiere es prestarle dinero a una
empresa entonces le voy a poner aquí
prestar dinero prestar dinero dinero a
empresa y empresa y vamos a poner que no
es cualquier empresa sino que es una
empresa que le está yendo muy bien que
está generando efectivo que le va bien
en en las depresiones económicas y así
bueno en las en las recesiones entonces
vamos a pensar que le prestamos dinero a
una empresa con buena reputación de
buena buena reputación de [ __ ]
ok entonces cómo se hace esto esto se
hace a través de bonos o sea vas la
empresa emite bonos eso quiere decir que
quiere que le presten dinero tú le
compras un bono lo guardas en tu cajón
te esperas un año y entonces pues tienes
un cierto retorno anual así que es
parecido a lo de la cuenta de ahorros y
más o menos que el retorno
bueno la tasa de interés en este caso lo
voy a poner aquí la recompensa
la recompensa es que te van a pagar un
cierto interés de digamos 6% de interés
anual
entonces te están pagando un poco más un
poco más que la cuenta de ahorros del
ipab y eso se debe a que ahora hay un
riesgo un poco más grande sea cual puede
ser el riesgo de prestarle tu dinero a
la empresa pues el riesgo es que la
empresa no pague o sea que haya un
incumplimiento incumplimiento
hundimiento de deuda de deuda y entonces
tú te preguntas cómo puede ser esto o
sea yo le presta la empresa tengo un
papelito entonces la empresa me tiene
que pagar o sea si en la mayoría de los
casos sí pero lo malo es que la empresa
puede caer en bancarrota si cae en
bancarrota su activo se va a depreciar
entonces al depreciarse no va a poder
pagarle a todos y tal vez tu bono fue de
baja prioridad y entonces pues la
empresa va a caer en incumplimiento de
deuda contigo y no te va a poder pagar
entonces hay un riesgo más grande que la
cuenta de ahorros del ipab en verdad
ahora no hay una institución que te
garantice que se te va a pagar lo que
depositas te y bueno ese riesgo está
compensado con
una recompensa mayor con una tasa de
interés más grande sale entonces esto es
prestar dinero a una empresa que está
generando una buena cantidad de efectivo
que ésta está muy bien ubicada en su
industria y lo que sea entonces tiene
una cierta tiene una cierta recompensa
que es más grande que la de acá pero
también su riesgo es mayor
bueno vamos a pensar en otra opción más
no sé ahora pensemos que hay un doctor
digamos que lo voy a poner de este color
que hay un doctor que se acaba de
titular en medicina de la unam ya tiene
su posgrado es muy bueno y entonces está
ganando mucho dinero va ahorita le pongo
cuánto pero la idea es que ese doctor
pues como acaba de salir de la carrera
quieres comprarse una casa y entonces
está buscando ayuda entre sus conocidos
y otras personas para poder pagar el
enganche de su casa le voy a poner aquí
enganche
gancho de la casa de la casa sale
entonces este doctor digamos que ya como
tiene tantos títulos y se fue a otras
universidades y lo que sea este pero se
está ganando muy bien y está ganando
digamos 500 mil pesos al año 500 mil
pesos al año
sale entonces al parecer pues es una
persona muy respetable lo que sea y él
está diciendo bueno préstame para mi
enganche para pagar lo de la casa y de
aquel aquel que me preste aquel que me
preste recompensa
aquel que me presta el dinero le voy a
pagar una tasa de interés del 8% anual
8% anual entonces si yo le presto estos
diez mil pesos paso enganche después de
un año él me va a dar diez mil 800 más
que prestarle dinero a la empresa y más
que sacar esta cuenta de ahorros
garantizada por el ipab bueno pero vamos
a pensar ahora en el riesgo en el riesgo
verá básicamente el riesgo el riesgo es
que no pague no pague
y entonces porque podría no pagar pues
si es un doctor muy reputado le está
ganando muy bien pues lo que sucede es
que las personas a bueno en comparación
con las empresas las personas tienen más
riesgos y por ejemplo este doctor de
repente puede tener problemas de salud y
puede ser que ya no pueda trabajar oa lo
mejor tiene una cierta personalidad
adictiva y no sé se vuelve adicto al
alcohol oa las drogas cientos ella no no
te puede pagar entonces hay un mayor
riesgo verdad las empresas pues tienen
digamos un activo al cual puedes
recurrir puedes hacer que te paguen
dándote pues su fábrica o dándote algún
coche sin embargo el doctor está recién
egresado entonces no tiene tantos bienes
que les puedan cobrar y pues también no
sea una empresa a una empresa no la
puede atropellar un camión de un día
para otro verdad pero a un doctor sí o
sea las empresas no se pueden volver
alcohólicas pero pues los doctores y
digo es una cosa que puede pasar o sea
básicamente la idea es que prestarle
este doctor tiene un riesgo mayor
entonces déjame ponerle aquí y el riesgo
es que no pague pero es un riesgo que va
a poner es un riesgo mayor que el de la
empresa vale entonces aquí el riesgo es
cumplimiento de deuda y el riesgo es más
o menos bajo es una empresa rentable y
es una empresa es una persona moral pero
acá es una persona física y el problema
es que están sujetas a más cosas
aleatorias vale bueno entonces ese es el
el doctor hizo enganche de la casa pero
a lo mejor dice sabes que el 8% todavía
no me acaba de convencer yo soy una
persona un poco más aventurera estoy
dispuesto a enfrentar un poquito más de
riesgo y he escuchado que en la bolsa de
valores puedo ganar más o menos como el
10 por ciento anual entonces esa es otra
opción una opción más es que en vez de
invertir en la cuenta de ahorros en la
empresa o en el doctor vayas a la bolsa
de valores le voy a poner aquí la bolsa
bolsa de valores de valores o sea ya
sabes a qué te dedicas a la compraventa
de acciones y qué andas siguiendo el
periódico y ves cómo van las acciones a
la alta y a la baja entonces eso es más
o menos la idea de la bolsa de valores y
la recompensa
la recompensa lo que lo que estás más o
menos esperando ganar pues es más o
menos como le esté yendo a la bolsa de
valores claro
el contexto depende del país digamos en
eeuu anda promediando como en un 10%
anual más o menos
anual entonces si podrías esperar un 10%
invirtiendo en wall street y todas estas
bolsas de valores este importante es per
igual en la bolsa mexicana de valores
pues puedes ir considerando algunos
portafolios de inversión y lo que sea y
bueno esta es otra opción ahora cuál es
el riesgo lo que pasa con los mercados
lo que sucede con los mercados es que
son inversiones como a mediano y largo
plazo con los mercados sucede que si
pasa nada más un año puede ser que haya
subido un 20% o que haya bajado un 20%
entonces tienes mucha volatilidad
entonces aquí el riesgo es la
volatilidad utilidad entonces cuál es el
problema pues puede ser que enfrentes
ciertos riesgos de liquidez a lo mejor
en un año tu dinero bajó 20 por ciento y
al año siguiente es nada más subió 10
por ciento y tienes que esperarte mucho
tiempo para que realmente se compense y
realmente tengas este 10% anual e
incluso puede suceder que pierdas tu
dinero totalmente si osea acá en la
empresa pues te pueden pagar un poquito
porque tienen bienes y tienen coches y
acá y así pero acá abajo como realmente
estás invirtiendo hombres pues en
capital verdad
aquí estás ya formando parte de la
apuesta y estás dispuesto a perderlo
todo básicamente entonces el gran riesgo
de la bolsa de valores es volatilidad
fíjate va aumentando la recompensa pero
también va aumentando el riesgo vamos a
un ejemplo más
un ejemplo un poco más extremo
supongamos que ahora tienes a tu cuñado
al cuñado va es el esposo es el esposo
el perdón del hermano de tu esposa y te
dice ay sabes que ya me falta bien
poquito me faltan diez mil pesos para
poder empezar mi negocio mágico de
producción de dinero y entonces con eso
voy a volverme millonario y quiero que
seas mi socio entonces bueno voy a
ponerle aquí recompensa recompensa en
este caso que podría pasar pues hay
varias formas de pensar en la recompensa
cuando cuando alguien te pide que
inviertas en su negocio puede ser a
través de deuda con el caso que
platicamos acá arriba pero puede ser a
través del capital es decir que el
cuñado te diga sabes que si inviertes tú
eres propietario del negocio bueno eres
parte propietario del negocio entonces
digamos que la recompensa es de 50 por
ciento
de del capital
capital para entonces tú eres dueño del
50 por ciento de las acciones y entonces
fíjate está padre porque puede ser que
sea tu cuñado le vaya muy bien que sí
tenga razón que su sistema de producción
de dinero sea magnífico y que entonces
pues le vaya a se vuelva un negocio
millonario entonces fue una buenísima
inversión verdad hay una recompensa
altísima por que invertiste 10 mil pesos
pero ahora eres dueño del 50 por ciento
de algo millonario entonces la
recompensa es muy alta va es muy alta lo
voy a poner así bueno si si le va bien
la posibilidad de recompensa es muy alta
sin embargo el riesgo aquí el riesgo es
muy grande el riesgo pues por un lado es
perder todo el dinero verdad perder todo
el dinero le voy a poner así perder todo
el dinero pero por otro lado es tu
cuñado entonces hay más riesgos este por
ahí verdad o sea puede ser que se quedan
en las relaciones familiares a lo mejor
en el próximo día de muertos pues ya no
va a estar tan padre saludar a tu cuñado
y le dices que se muera o algo así
entonces bien la navidad también va a
ser muy muy grave a lo mejor ya no va a
invitarlo
el día de la candelaria vaya se pueden
dañar realmente las relaciones
familiares y entonces pues voy a ponerle
por aquí también inestabilidad
inestabilidad
unidad familiar familiar además pues
esto de un esquema mágico de ganar
dinero pues suena a que tiene muchas
probabilidades de fallar entonces aquí
el riesgo es muy muy alto también que no
sólo no sólo es muy probable que falle
sino que al fallar además hay mucho en
juego ok entonces fíjate cuál es la
tendencia la tendencia básicamente es
que mientras más recompensa obtengas por
algo
mientras más posibilidad de recompensa
tengas entonces hay un mayor riesgo
inherente si osea pasamos de no tener
nada de riesgo a incluso poder tener
inestabilidad familiar y perder todo tu
dinero el riesgo va creciendo conforme
va creciendo la recompensa otra forma de
decirlo es que si esperas tener una
mayor recompensa entonces debes de estar
dispuesto a tomar un mayor riesgo
entonces mira bueno vamos a hacer una
gráfica para que más o menos ya quede
claro esto último la voy a poner de este
lado entonces déjame poner en este eje
de por acá
voy a ponerle algo así
así entonces aquí le voy a poner que
quede un poco fea déjame déjame volver a
graficar la cara con un poco más de
espacio entonces algo así algo así ok
entonces de este lado voy a poner riesgo
y todavía no te he dicho cómo se mide el
riesgo pero si los académicos se han
dedicado a dar ciertas medidas de riesgo
aquí voy a poner recompensa
piensa y estas medidas de riesgo las
veremos después pero ahorita sin nada
más en términos más o menos abstractos
que nos sucedía con la cuenta de ahorros
pues con la cuenta de ahorros no
teníamos nada nada de riesgo y estábamos
aquí pero teníamos una recompensa del 1
por ciento digamos más o menos algo de
este estilo
luego cuando prestamos dinero a la
empresa que tenía una buena reputación
entonces pues pues teníamos una
recompensa del 6 por ciento digamos como
por acá y el riesgo aumentaba no voy a
mover a la derecha para indicar que es
mayor riesgo aunque no te he dicho cómo
medirlo estaba más o menos por acá luego
cuando pasamos al doctor la recompensa
era del 8 por ciento no aumentó
tantísimo verdad pero el riesgo sí
aumentó un poco más algo de este estilo
en la bolsa de valores la recompensa
ahora del 10 por ciento pero había un
riesgo de volatilidad entonces digamos
que estamos como por acá
y el caso del cuñado del cuñado que le
prestas para su esquema mágico de dinero
pues la recompensa podría ser muy alta
la posibilidad de recompensa entonces
podría estar digamos como por acá más o
menos de altura bueno por acá para que
quepa en mi dibujito pero el riesgo es
muy muy alto incluso fuera de este de
esta gráfica de acá entonces supongamos
que lo del cuñado está más o menos por
aquí entonces básicamente la idea que te
quiero dejar y que es muy importante es
que conforme vamos aumentando el riesgo
entonces tenemos una mayor posibilidad
de recompensas o bien si queremos
obtener una mayor recompensa por nuestra
inversión entonces debemos estar
dispuestos a tomar más riesgos